so
so let's do it in the order if i watched
that i read them yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah go go for it okay so next up was
one punch man okay yeah so what what
inspired you to read one punch man i
guess the animator yeah season one was
too good
how can you you can't [ __ ] block me like
that right like season one was so good
yeah yeah and uh i saw the manga and i
was like oh
a lot of the times when i'd see the
manga and i when i wanted to go further
like past the anime i would start
reading the mag and everything ah it's
not the same yeah
but one pancho was the one where i was
like holy [ __ ] this is insane yeah like
this this artwork is just insane yeah i
noticed you have two murata yusuke manga
yeah i love his art man
and he's so good at visually conveying
like action action and also just kind of
like metaphors i've seen god yeah let's
talk about i i swear like because i
think especially in sports anime yeah
sports anime a lot of times live and die
by the metaphor yeah right right because
how cause concepts need to be explained
yeah yeah because like how can you
convey a certain move or a certain like
aspect of a sport that people who are do
not understand a sport can easily
understand you go for metaphors and by
far the manga that does the best of
visual metaphors is i sure 21. you know
[ __ ] your high q and your [ __ ]
christmas
this is why i would want him to do a
chat out of me you would explain the
concepts of chess through metaphors
yeah yeah like this is a pin and he'd
figure out some weird [ __ ] way of
showing it i would love that but yeah
sadly it's not popular in japan
big rip but yeah one punch man i i just
like dude this one was still to this day
one of my favorite mangas out of all of
these i still think that one punch man
is
maybe one of my favorites right it's so
hard it's yeah that's the difficult one
because you have jojo because jojo is
there as well and i think jojo might be
my favorite obviously um
but ah i think jojo is my fa is it like
because i have a difference between my
favorite and the one i enjoyed the most
yeah right and i think i enjoyed one
punch man the most because it was just
pure fun yeah but jojo is my favorite
because there's so much about jojo that
i love yeah yeah and i love the style of
jojo i love all of that and i feel like
giorgio is so much more than just the
margaret it's experienced
you know you don't just read jojo you
believe it you live it you experience it
you become jojo there's just something
about jojo which we'll talk about later
about like yeah just there's something
about it um but one punch man man like i
finished season one and i was like okay
i'm gonna check it out i'ma see what
happens after yeah because it ends
because i mean after you watch the boros
fight uh which you know if you haven't
if you don't know what one punch man is
i'm gonna explain to you it's a guy who
beats everyone in one punch that's
literally it and he's a man and at the
end of the season one of the anime he
has this amazing fight that is so
visually stunning yeah and just amazing
and it's so hype but it's probably one
of the coolest animated fights in anime
yeah
and i was like okay i have to know where
this can go because everyone's saying
the story is amazing onwards so i
started reading it and i was like oh
okay this is pretty cool the next arc
starts and i'm like okay this is really
interesting right because we start the
uh what's known as the monster arc yeah
and the garo arc
yeah and they introduced gara which is
like the one of the main characters
going forward in the in the anime and
manga and season two covers uh i'd
probably say the beginning just barely
the beginning of one of the
it's a long rock yeah it's very long
it's still ongoing on the on the manga
um yeah i started reading it and i was
like god damn this man's drawings are
just another level yeah yeah actually
insane it's it's insane because i
remember reading one punch man before
the anime came out because everyone was
hyping it up so i was like it was the
one show when i'm just like let me just
see let me just read like a chapter or
two just to see you can't read what can
i what i can expect so i tried reading a
chapter or two and then i read
everything that was out you can't then
you can't pick that up and not read
everything that's impossible and then i
remember reading and being like there's
no way the anime is going to live up to
this fight
i was just like there's no [ __ ] way
but like not not because the r is like i
think some of the best art that's
available i mean that there's
when you turn the pa there's a panel
right where saitama punches so hard yeah
the clouds split yeah yeah and in this
panel you like the detail on the earth
yeah and the clouds is insane no there's
there's some panels that are literally
just animated keyframes yeah where you
read it and it's it's it's just like
it's just like an anime because it's
just basically keyframes right so like i
was very very impressed at you know the
team at mad house for being being able
to put their own spin on his amazing
[ __ ] art yeah like living up to this
amazing art but even without that one
punch man is some of the best battle
shown in like 100 arts yeah that you can
find in all of anime and manga yeah and
i think that
we're i'm very glad that one punch man
season one was animated the way there
was because i think anime season one
is more of a comedy yeah and then season
two onwards is an action i feel like the
comedy very much takes a backseat after
the first arc well yeah because i mean
you can only do so much with that single
concept right yeah but but like the way
that they made it work every time was so
genius and funny like one punch man
season one is one of the funniest shows
in anime yeah and in the manga i feel
that although the art is much better i
feel like the comedy doesn't hit as hard
because the comedic timing is super
important for jokes and i feel like you
can't have as good comedic timing when
you're reading something as when you're
experiencing it the joke i think i think
it's just like a different experience
already different it's a different but a
joke a joke read aloud will always be
funnier than a joke you've read like
that's just uh
i don't know i disagree
i thought that too until i read like
stuff like guinta
yeah but i bet the gintama animes
delivers the lines funnier
i don't know it's hard to say like
sometimes it does yes but then there are
some chapters that i i think gintama is
the only manga that's genuinely made me
laugh out loud reading
yeah and that's like a very powerful
thing to say right because like
again it's like as you said a joke is
much funnier said out loud yeah but it's
like timing timing you know everything
playing into the joke yeah there's so
many aspects that can help elevate the
joke i think that i think that comes
down to at least with manga how good you
are at like framing yeah right and i
think munata yusuke is so [ __ ] good
at framing yeah like a concept yeah that
he can just somehow do that with comedy
as well but he already proved it with
actual 21's like action scenes right
yeah and he this man can also do comedy
as well i'm like what can this man not
do yeah i've read the original one
webcomic oh yeah yeah how was that
yeah it's it's a it's a lot harder to go
to
um
but also i know so explain one can't
draw yeah
so the original the original yeah the
original uh one punch mine is a webcam
i'm sure you guys know this it's a web
comic and then another yusuke picked it
up and was like hey let me draw good for
you like real good yeah and and then
published and shown in not jump it used
to be jump right jump plus jump plus now
right it's once a month which is painful
because i think uh juan did weekly is it
i believe the webcomic is over now right
is it um kind of like it's not over it's
just on hiatus oh okay because i've read
up to everything that's out and it's
just kind of in the middle of an arc
right now
but like the manga
right now is adapting
the it's so it's in the monster ark
style yeah it's it's still in the
monster arc so it's taking the webcomic
it's kind of like a like a basis and
just really expanding on that yeah i've
noticed because that they've
in the the difference between the hmong
and the webcomic is that they've put
aspects of the story that happened
they've moved them around yeah the manga
into like better timings yeah yeah like
there's some characters that got their
backstory um
in the webcomic at a certain time that
they were shifted to them when they were
having a fight yeah they got the
flashback and their backstory uh like
there's a superhero called super black
alloy
who is a man that is super muscular yeah
that's his thing and he gets his
flashback at a different time but in the
actual uh the redone manga he gets it
during one of his fights with garu right
um which i noticed was like oh okay
that's interesting i didn't i didn't
know they were mixing things around yeah
um but yeah the manga is
oh my god just take a one look at some
of these panels and you'll be you'll be
yeah you'll be reading it yeah yeah it's
definitely one of the best action manga
i've ever read if not the best honestly
uh yeah it's hard i can't think of
anything that in terms of pure action
and fights that comes close in mind yeah
i mean i haven't read many so i can't
say but i mean i still think it's one of
the best it's definitely the best yeah